so I'd like to talk about our work on ab
initio solutions of the many schrodinger
many electron trading occasion using
deep neural networks
this work was joining done with David
Hardy mind along with Alex Matthews also
do you mind and my longtime friend and
collaborator Matthew Fox from Imperial
College and there's a link to our
archive treatment the next like he's so
the electronic structure from it I find
I find rich and invigorating but also
extremely frustrating its it's complex
and whilst it seems somewhat academic
you know kind of obscure it has come
profound role model occasions from and
if we could understand it the
electron-electron interaction better I
think it's fair to say we could design
better drugs design better cat medical
event catalyst I understand in the
middle how nitrogenase does so much
better if exciting night nitrogen then
than the harper process for example and
what am i missed one of my favorite
examples of quantum mechanics is is that
it was trading 2002 that the reason
geckos walking walking walking wars is
using band of ours interact it's due to
Van der Waals interactions use
incredibly weak short-range interactions
yeah I never that I saw us strong throw
enough to support its weight and lost
the one emphasized these these
interactions are extremely subtle and we
must be extreme in order to obtain
experimentally relevant predictions we
need to be extremely accurate so what's
the total energy of say the nitrogen
molecule is around minus 109 Hartree
the binding energy is only about half a
percent of that so the total energies
can be extremely large but the actually
the actually required to obtain
predictions relevant to experiment is
really it is really extreme getting
ninety-five percent of the way to the
total energy is just it's just nowhere
near a good enough and in the bottom
left corner is easier one of my
favorites pictures from
quantum mechanics in this from Ashley
from David 70 back in 91 we're sure how
complicated the neural structure but
it's where the wave function goes to
zero for electron gases then this talk
will show you the using a structured
neural network I think I think will
provide a compelling and compact and
accurate representation of the many
electron wave function and also that we
require
second order methods second with
optimization methods in order to obtain
training results in a feasible amount of
computational time next slide please
so well completely we're looking to
solve they're showing the many electron
Schrodinger equation that is the
operation of the electron electron
electronic kinetic energy with the
electron-electron interaction the
electron nuclear interaction and finally
the the nuclear nuclear interaction for
many nuclear system for many other
systems we can find the wave function
for this option that energy of the
system is minimized and there are a
whole plethora of techniques from dating
back to the 30s right from the start of
quantum mechanics and we have a move
most methods start from hot Rifat which
the mean field approximation and then we
have things like configuration
interaction which is a linear
combination of determinants from hard
orbitals the couple cluster on sites
which is substantially more compact than
configuration interaction and we also
have quantum Monte Carlo techniques such
as variation one to colleague which we
will be using today when you optimize
functions de Castille E and then
diffusion Montecarlo which gives you the
exact energy of a wave function subject
to an external constraint normally from
a variation on two poly wave function
and there are many many other methods
but these will start many of them start
at least from hartree-fock and i think a
key issue is how we represent wave
functions and next slide please well the
only thing that a wave function is
required to do is required to be it must
be antisymmetric and then this is
because electrons are fermions and there
is always a totally symmetric solution
to the Schrodinger equation which is at
least as good and normally
actually lower in energy than their anti
symmetric wave function so you don't
impose anti symmetry your collapse onto
a bitonic state that is is non-physical
and and this is the thing that really
makes quantum mechanics for electrons
extremely low and its focus so the most
common ins use me the most
computationally tractable way of
imposing enter symmetry is simply to
represent the wave function is it
determined or sum of determinants of a
single particle in orbitals that is
orbitals Phi which only depend upon a
single electron over time and this
waving down over in here is actually
partial Fox they're just the best single
determinant next weekís so we can go
beyond this for example we can include a
symmetric term in front of the
determinant just requires to be
symmetric and this can introduce
electron electron coronations so this is
called the state of Joshua wave function
next slide please but nothing requires
orbitals to be a function of single
electrons we can have because we know
that my function E is really a many
electron table objects and the the key
issue is how do we represent this
functions how can we express the
function and easily intractably
evaluated in particular for the
intercourse require things like health
and for hartree-fock type approaches
having to represent T single and
available next time please and say the
code mentioned earlier that with hockey
for common methods used are from you
express your orbitals in an underlying
basis for this reason to be able to
easily evaluate neutrals and they're
typically used and we typically use
Gaussian functions for that so the idea
of expressing an orbital in terms of
many electrons is not new that dates
back to this firemen and the 50s and
really pioneering work by Davis every
and many others in that from the 90s
onwards applying it to the electron
electron that the many electron and the
key insight is that if we take an
orbital
we should depend upon a single orbit or
a single electron position and instead
Express have a funk and replace it with
a function that depends upon a single
electron I and all other electrons
subject to the fact that it must be
invariant under the change of any other
of any of the other electrons then if we
could try to determine if these
functions the determinant remains
totally anti-symmetric we can naturally
capture many electron interactions
directly in the orbital and this
approach is used by battery functions in
variation and color and diffusion
multicolor in particular well I guess
the key problem now is how do we
represent these permutation of covariant
functions and in this later just rode
back wave functions we typically use a
fixed functional form with a small
number maybe a few thousand parameter up
to a few thousand parameters and you
optimize that but can we do better than
a fixed function of all next white keys
um so we and I'm sure given the title of
this conference and many others here
will be exploiting the fact that neural
networks are excellent function
approximate us and and machine learning
has had deep and profound impact on
almost every fear that has entered in
last you know asked a few years we've
seen a rapid explode special not just in
terms of the interest but also in terms
of the result achieved from from protein
folding to glass understanding glasses
to understanding quantum chemistry next
wavers so we so one way or starting is
thinking just about a single electron so
this is the simplest possible case you
can have a single electron and we feed
it into and you'll know where I can
alpha on your network here ISM is a
multi-layer perceptron where each layer
essentially is composers or it's
composed of a set of matrix
multiplications with the inputs and some
weights with a bias term added on and
then fed through an element-wise non
singularity
non any singularity sorry nonlinear
activation function and then that's
passed on to an arbitrary number
of these hidden layers and to you until
finally we spit out in this case a
single result at the end of the network
or weight function next focus and the
power of machine learning is really that
it can compactly express functions that
are extremely client dimension so if we
want to go to more than one electron
then we can easily handle this with by
feeding into the network the positions
of each electron at a time and we just
need to require we just need to spit out
rather than assume the orbital we need
to spit out to commence and then we can
pass this into determinant and this is
essentially hydrophobe Theory expressly
expressed with a neural network
but how do we go beyond the single
electron picture and this is the
motivation for thrown out we want to
continue the idea the ideas from machine
learning of britain come away from fixed
functional forms as much as possible and
see where it leads us
next life is so I'm gonna spend quite a
bit of time on this safer with firming
it we the key idea is that we start with
the electron say a set of electron
coordinates I'm off and we can construct
rank one features that has features that
depend only upon a single electron
position such as the distance from the
electron and nucleus or the vector the
distance and we can also have create
rank to you features that is electron
electron vectors and distances we have a
structured network so we feed the feed
ranked one and write to you data into an
equi variant a permutation equal variant
which I'll discuss more on the next
slide but crucially what it produces if
from the rank one around two features or
produce permutation equal variant
functions that are running we're then
feed the a-pillar from the permutation a
covariant block into a
Linnea Leia and we repeat I'm foreign
for several hours here I show you three
three such layers and finally we we have
a single a single linear layer which
takes the output of the of the block
firming let me tell me now layers
firming that blocks and shapes it into
their current required number of
orbitals we then evaluate the terms of
these matrices and final wave functions
are learned linear combination of the
determinants but crucially we in
parallel to this one election
information we also have we also have a
two electron stream which is fed through
a just a standard MRP and at the output
of each layer is communicated back into
the next permutation a covariant walk
and we find that this has a substantial
improve substantially impact on actually
of the wave revision that's more show
you later
next slide please so in the permutation
maker very block we take the series of
Rank 1 features that is things that it
initially only depend upon a single
electron and we combine them in a way
that's permutation with the equivariance
I'm the easiest way to do this is to say
that some or me all of the all of these
terms or we can also do the same with
the rank TV the right to information so
we can make and we don't so we go from
from right wanna go from n such
information to us to for ranked their
own information and from for the right
ear we go from N squared 2 to order n
movers by combining them in a
conversation there anyway we then take
the permutation that were variant
functions and we concatenate them with
the corresponding initial input right
over N quantum activations as shown on
the right hand side and then within each
row of the of the outputs of the
permutation the block is kind of is
related to essentially a single electron
but I'm composers of wear depends itself
on all other electrons in a permutation
you know programming way which is
exactly what we want to in order to
achieve a compact and express that wave
function next life is so we can then
take the wave function and we can
optimize it by minimizing minimizing the
energy of the wave function we do this
using standard variation Monte Carlo
with sample configurations from the net
according to the output of the network
the square of the output of the network
we then evaluate the wave functions
energy and the green to the end you
inspect the with respect to the
parameters and use this to minimize the
wave function there are a few technical
issues with this one is that if we can't
just randomly initialize the weights in
the network this tends to be extremely
far
the ground state solution and is also
likely to have linear dependencies in
the layers which which causes the
determines to blow up have you seen yeah
so we circumvent this through
pre-training of the network against
hartree-fock minimum dataset but after
the pre-training is done we no longer
require any information smartphone I do
it and we deliberately do a fairly bad
job others pre-training it also makes
sure the determinant the network starts
off in a relatively noisy position so we
didn't get stuck in local minima and
also importantly we take very very great
care if the gradients of the
determinants so even if the determent is
singular if derivative can still be
well-defined and we we very careful to
implement and finally we aborted to
implement this carefully in order to
obtain think emergence rather than
hitting lands
and finally we observe face load
convergence of of the optimization and
we find that as crucible to use second
automation methods next like these so
they do so in particular we use chronica
factor to approximate curvature the key
fab method which is an approximate
second-order method design for neural
networks it exploits information about
the network and its structure to to have
a block diagonal approximation to the
Fisher matrix which is computationally
much more efficient to invert and also
much more compact store in a sparse
matrix representation and this
essentially an approximation to another
gradient descent and stochastic
reconfiguration and we we observe
compared to add one which is a
first-order approximation method that
k5 requires an order of magnitude at
least fewer iterations and this we see
this on on all but the smallest systems
and it got it seemed to increase with
system size so here I show the
conversion to film with iam through to
neon atoms relative to essentially exact
results from Chakravarti at or a talent
three and rally to talk I'll use this
gray region to indicate chemically
relative relative to baseball where
chemical XE is 1.6 military next slide
please
so let's start by comparing Fermi net
against conventional Montecarlo results
on us and here we'll just use a single
determinant for carbon nitrogen oxygen
fluorine and neon and this is from
really exceptional work by by back in
2011 really really familiar very careful
job of the optimization and they show
you that work for the VMC level with a
single determinant Slater Josh trip the
state of Joshua wavefunction is between
two and three million arteries high but
incorporating the back flow reduces this
this point by over a factor of two next
slide please so first we implemented
your network equivalent of the Slater
just Drew and Stacy just right actually
functions and in both cases we see that
this is this provides a slightly but non
negligible lowering in the energy and
this is likely due to the neural
networks offering a much more flexible
functional form and this under say the
surprising because saffet are used
numerical so they did not have a they're
already at the basic set and next slide
please
and then in you know at the bottom we
have firma net and we show that
furminator
this shows that foaming out
substantially reduces the error further
um
well beyond would this phase josh wave
actually architecture coaching next like
these and we can further increase the
accuracy by outputting
not just one determinant but a series of
determinants from from the network and
then combine them in a linear
combination to produce the final wave
function
and it and when you we find that 16
determinants is a is a wonderful
trade-off between accuracy and
computational cost so here we show you
the energy of the ground state energy
for a series of atoms from from the
lithium through to the neon and in all
cases we we substantially outperformed
conventional very romantic are
devastated after a factory function in
yellow and this is this is now using the
VMC wave functions now using 50 to 100
configuration state functions which
depending upon the system maps to
between a hundred seventy and four and a
half thousand determinants so then using
substantially more determinants now
interestingly enough we also perform at
equivalent or or outperform the oxy of
diffusion Monte Carlo and top of the DMC
wave function also shown is the couple
cluster with singles and double trouble
excitations are the complete base
extrapolated to the complete basis at
the limit which we substantially up form
and we also up are essentially
equivalent to or CCSD with eternity for
triples corrosion and also a complete
basis limit and they hear that unlike on
activate the MCM DMC CCSD and CCSD
princes - you're not variation and
across throughout this we consistently
capture at least ninety-nine point seven
percent of the correlations which i
think is really really impressive result
and next slide please
we've also studied a range of molecules
so ranging from lithium hydride with
four electrons up to by cyclobutane with
30 electrons and whilst we see some
actually depredation with a number of
electrons and this is like this could be
used for many reasons private problems
with the optimization
improvements that required to Monte
Carlo algorithm but also we have a fixed
functional fix Network configurations
all these calculations so the number of
prompts we have available does not
increase substantially with system size
so for comparison by cyclobutane
calculations around 700,000 parameters
whereas the couple cluster could
rosita calculation has over twenty two
and a half million parameters
again next slide please so we're running
short so we need we will select at the
wave function itself it was not very
much as named analytically one thing
that is known is that behavior the
behavior of the wave function at where
two electrons coincide or where the
electron and nucleus coincide and we
show this for the helium atom here and
this must be non smooth in order to
cancel out the similarities in the
Hamiltonian due to the one over R
potential and when we see that it
received the shop characteristic sharp
features at the origin in the top lot
for the electron-nuclear class and also
below the zero angle for the electron
reduction cusp we've evaluated the
relationship between the gradient of the
wave function and the weight value of
the wave function both casts and for the
electron nucleic acid we find it of
course on TK minus 0.99 and for the
electron electron cusp to be point 493
which is an excellent agreement with the
MC values of minus 2 and 1/2
respectively next slide please
I thought jr.
you might have like five minutes okay
thank you
so here we show we studied the impact of
changing the features of the network for
fed into the network to the oxygen atom
and interesting we find that we actually
require the electronic island distances
for stable training this is likely due
to acquiring it in order to model the
electron-nuclear cusp accurately at
least in the initial stages of training
and we also find that the
electron-electron interactions are
really important so without them a tool
we are our error is around 90 mil
ahartry
yet with both the electron electron
vector and the electron electron
distance the arrow dropped by towards
the magnitude to 0.8 apart next slide
please and this shows the convergence of
not just a minute but also later just
rated Network the states just right now
we're going to take such a straight back
we now work with number of determinants
and we find that phone that converges
zoom Europeans
with number exam so this is relative to
CCSD princess T at the complete basis at
limit and we don't see substantial
improvements the on theta to you and not
really much improvement after sixty and
I just like to mention that firming it
is is substantially easier to optimize
not experienced than don't stated after
a backflow isolated jester about
framework this guy first firming that
neck competition we get around one oven
the stator Josh I got afraid at all it
took
substantial my wife to get stable
convergence next Loki's
we also studied 4-h 10 and here we use
this one for study from what a tower
from NPR X from 2017 as reference the
convergence of 4-h 10 weather South Asia
hydrogen atoms separated by two ball and
we study the energy with both number of
layers the width of the one electron
stream and the width of the two electron
stream with number of layers we see a
fairly rapid convergence we will see if
they interesting enough we ostia very
rapid convergence in the two electron
stream which surprised me I thought we
really need to capture these very
accurately the key difference appears to
be we just need some internet from its
mission well once you have some you
don't really need very much more I think
a more promising Avenue is is expanding
the width of the one electron stream the
number of hidden units the night stream
where even by 256 in the unit which is
up has been a conventional setup for
with calculations I've shown we trainees
do not know next type these so it's been
a kind of a really wonderful explosion
of interest in just in this topic over
the last few years and I'm really
looking forward to hearing about much of
this work from from from the authors of
edit doing over the course what meeting
by just like a highlights I can't really
say Luhan Clark used new net you're now
back home I noticed another model
they're traumatized and the battery
function within your network using a
first-order
optimization method either rmsprop or a
customer optimization method some
related to our prop and they don't
relate is substantially surpasses the
convention of actually function for the
hub water which is another system and
the extension to to continue tomorrow
because in the continuing I think it's
not trivial I mean surely after our
paper hit archive there was work on from
the know I grew up on Park called poly
net where they also victim Walla cousin
continuum they parameterize the just row
and back flow functions optimizing you
stoned
Adam so they have fewer crimson offices
likely to be much easier to optimize
and that energy czar for boron they
obtained obtained 97.3% the correlation
energy and for the for the hydrogen
chain of ten items they obtained a
correlation between 1998 and while the
performance degrades as she starts the
more with you any for us interests from
color at all kind of was a really
wonderful and a very novel approach
where they mapped the many firmly on
problem to spin problem and then they
work in the second quantized space and
so they required underlying basis set
and then they saw a bit using abstract
Boltzmann machine mister Catholic
reconfiguration they obtained submit
ahartry error compared to for
configuration interaction albeit in a in
a minimal basis and the error for
example nitrogen in the space the
National donor for in this base set
completely limit is substantially the
factor it's around to pottery and
finally I'll work well we also work on
workers and continuing with basically
everything and some computation of
overhead for sure I'm gonna use a
approximate a scaleable second-order
quantized optimization with a fact and
we obtained for boron a correlation in
GF 99% might on point eight percent of
correlation energy and over 99 98 M
accent the correlation energy across the
edge standpoint and I'd just like to
highlight this really neat baby from
Bulgaria tour which studied iterative
near another back flows and then applied
it case of of tritium next focused so
just conclude and sermonette is a
structure of neural network Quentin wave
functions we use a powerful scalable
optimization method I have a committee
that we have actor of ground state
energies with only physically motivated
inputs and neural networks prevent
provide flexible and compact
representations of complex high
dimensional functions by thing there's
still plenty outstanding questions I
think we have three James thank you very
much for your attention